[Music]
Riverdale left us with some huge
bombshells and some major cliffhangers
last season here is what we already know
about the third season of The CW's hit
show stay tuned to find out what we are
most excited about in season 3 love
river del be sure to subscribe to the
things for more awesome content now here
are 10 things we already know about
season 3 of river del release date we
won't leave you waiting anymore
we know the biggest question you have is
windows River del return we officially
have a release date Riverdale will
return to the CW on October 10th 2018
which is a Wednesday night it returns to
its normal time slot at 8:00 p.m.
Eastern 7:00 p.m. central the creator's
know how much everyone missed Riverdale
because it is returning one week earlier
than season two did Thank You CW now we
just have to figure out what we're
supposed to do until October we can't
wait to see what happens to Archie and
the gang Archie on trial speaking of
what happens to Archie season 3 will
have him on trial
we know he was framed for the murder of
Cassidy bullet but the new antagonist is
the prosecuting attorney miss Wright who
is absolutely certain Archie is guilty
she is going to be a serious problem she
tries to paint Archie as a violent
sociopath it excuse us not our Archie
miss Wright is going to be played by
actress Penelope Ann Miller who you may
recognize from Carlito's Way
Archie's freedom is up in the air the
season 3 sure hope justice prevails for
our favorite lead character Time Warp
season 3 opens on Labor Day weekend
which is the first weekend of September
that means it's a new school year it
looks like after two seasons our
characters will finally become juniors
in high school although they've seen
enough awful stuff for a lifetime they
are going to be super mature high school
students after dealing with a serial
killer and gang wars our main four
characters will spend Labor Day weekend
at a lake house trying to forget all the
terrible stuff that's going on we can't
say we blame them the town
Riverdale is stressful AF Veronica Lodge
entrepreneur in the sneak peak Veronica
tells us she is not a victim Veronica
Lodge is not a victim nor will she ever
allow herself to be one sure some bad
stuff has happened but she is determined
to prove she is strong
she's also determined to prove that she
is not a spoiled little rich girl even
though her dad is a corrupt politician
Veronica is an awesome driven character
she's going to run a speakeasy out of
pops an underground nightclub where she
also works at weird ride things look a
little better for her than they are for
her boyfriend Veronica Lodge is hustle
goals and she looks fabulous while she
works her rear end off to Archie's
jalopy sometimes it's easy to forget
that this dark show is based on the
light hearted comics that debuted in
1941 so we really love it when the
show's creators throw in a tribute to
the comic books Archie and his dad fix
up this old car or a de Lappe that is in
terrible shape in the sneak peak Archie
tells Betty Veronica and Jughead that he
just wants them to have a normal Labor
Day weekend then we see all four of them
in this old car that is straight out of
the comics so much nostalgia don't you
just love the throwback we do Betty's
got issues poor Betty in season one she
found her sister pregnant in a halfway
house in season two she found out whole
dad is a serial killer no wonder she has
some major issues in the new season she
will have just spent some time at a
summer internship trying to forget about
her dad's crimes but her sister and mom
have become so wrapped up with two new
characters that it's going to cause some
serious issues
Edgar ever never and his daughter Evelyn
run the farm which is super creepy they
try to pull Betty in with the help of
her mother and sister Betty wants
nothing to do with the creeps it's a
good thing she and Jughead our
relationship goals think that's crazy
stay tuned for the most exciting
announcement from season three the farm
the farm is the weird cult that Polly
got involved in and she pulled Alice
into the creepy mess - Edgar ever never
is the leader and he's helped Alice with
all her issues surrounding how it sure
seems like he solved all her issues
really fast since we just found out
about how being a serial killer a few
months ago Alice has a you hippie chick
look this season suggesting that she is
fully giving herself over to this new
cult and in the sneak peak we see a
terrifying scene with Alice and some
other women dancing around a fire and
holding babies over the flames creepy AF
filming has begun as of July 6 2018 the
cast of Riverdale was back in Vancouver
they did the first table read of the
first script one of the writers shared
an awesome photo of the cast at dinner
after the table read they've done some
filming because the sneak peek was
released at Comic Con on July 22nd 2018
we are so excited we know there will be
23 episodes in season 3 which is one
more than in season 2 the first two
episodes titles have been released as
well episode 1 is called chapter 36
Labor Day and episode 2 is called
chapter 37 Fortune and men's eyes oMG it
is going to be so good
jugheads family one of the most exciting
announcements about season 3 of
Riverdale is that we will finally meet
jugheads mom and sister Gladys and
jellybeans jugheads life hasn't really
been easy and we're sure that there will
be some drama with these two characters
what does this mean for Jughead and his
father we know that they won't appear
until at least episode 8 or 9 so we have
a while till we find out do you think
they'll be a good addition to jugheads
life we sure hope so at least he has
Betty to keep him happy flashback and
now for the plot points that we're most
excited about there will be a flashback
in season 3 we will get to see all of
the parents in high school what was
Alice like as a team what made Hal
become the bad guy was Hyrum always so
convincing was Fred a heartthrob like a
son we have so many questions we can't
wait to see all these parents as teens
we have a feeling they had just as much
drama as Archie and his friends drama
just seems to come naturally in
Riverdale what are you most excited
about for season 3 let us know in the
comments
and that's what we know about season 3
of Riverdale be sure to subscribe and
give this video a big thumbs up
[Music]